stalling a convention does not get you
the requisite votes for changing the
Constitution it simply brings people to
a room who then argue again and so can
you can you can make amendments to the
Constitution which then have to be voted
on and ratified by the states but
independent but independent of DC yes
and then we don't have enough states to
even call a convention and if we did I
would say half of the red states are
going to go slow down there dab of craps
and then do nothing you're not wrong but
the uh but so what we have right now is
we are in an abusive relationship where
we're being pummeled and beaten in the
face and people are going but if but if
you leave him you'll be homeless and I'm
like I'd rather sleep under a bridge the
point the point is
you have to exhaust the legal means that
that are afforded to the population for
for any for any anything to be
legitimate you have to go through all
legal means First National divorce is
the statement
asking for a legal it is but again you
are you're enabling what I believe is
behind the disillusion of America or the
disillusion of us as a people you're
giving them exactly what they want
because I care what they want yeah well
that's not an argument I think it is an
argument because if you if you're
playing into what the plan is because
it'll be worse after you don't have the
protection of the Constitution albeit it
may be weakened I just I disagree states
have their own constitutions it's like
saying my significant other is
mercilessly beating me demanding I leave
the house but if I do leave I'll be
giving them exactly what they want it's
like or you leave and then you stop
getting beaten and then you'll be
responsible for yourself so I'm not
saying a national divorce is the
guaranteed absolute way to solve these
problems I'm just saying the argument
that we should sit here take the abuse
and then cross our fingers is also not
an answer but you also have you can
fight back through the legal means to
stop these things and you have more you
have more tools to be able to do that
within within the system that we have
within the Constitutional system that we
have lawsuits have just barely begun
right exactly lawsuits have just barely
begun this is the the the the naivety
okay California will do will not stop
these the these cult members are
hell-bent on imposing everything about
their psychosis on the rest of the
country and the other side which is
independent conservative post-liberal or
whatever are saying please leave me
alone but please leave me alone doesn't
stop abusers from trying to destroy you
and harm your children and so we're at a
point now where that we've got Marjorie
Taylor green and other people like
Michael malice and lucurkowski among
many others saying maybe a peaceful
divorce a national divorce and now you
have many conservatives coming out
saying no that's a bad idea because then
we lose this we lose that we lose this
and I'm like actually I think the cities
will collapse in two seconds without the
rural areas that prop them up these
people seem to think that National
divorce means state borders no no no
that's not what it means at all it
likely would mean if you look at the
secession movement in Oregon and Eastern
Oregon it would strip the rural Farmland
from the cities that are oppressing them
and the people in eastern Oregon are
trying to secede first and foremost just
from Portland basically so that they can
join Idaho and be it working with a
community that more agrees with them
that's step one that's not even National
divorce and Portland says F you know
because the people who live in eastern
Portland are poorer but produce the food
and the resources the city needs to
survive you cut that off the city ceased
to exist in two seconds so if there was
a national divorce I'd imagine Los
Angeles New York Portland Chicago Etc
would crumble and people would panic and
it would be sheer chaos as they went to
farms and desperately begged you for
food now California as a state produces
a ton of food but the parts that produce
the food are all conservative so what
would happen if there was a national
divorce what but the people in
California be like guess we're stuck
with California or would they be like
the borders are dissolving we're with
that but you also have to remember that
the people producing the food make their
money and they're living by selling the
food to the cities so if they're not
selling the food to the cities to the
people who eat it then they're not
making money either so it's within their
it's it's in their best interest to keep
that you don't leverage I know I know
it's leverage I get it but it but it's
also it's it's leverage
why is it that the cities have leverage
over the people the workers why is it
that the guy who works at BuzzFeed and
writes articles about Brad Pitt's junk
is getting four times the income of a
dude who works the field picking crops
how does that make sense we as Society
value a dude who goes on the internet
and says Donald Trump is Hitler more
than a guy who grows the food we need to
eat that makes no sense and if there was
some kind of let me got to call it a
national divorce some kind of
restructuring and an assertion of the
leverage and the and the authority of
those who actually make this country
work then you would see cities collapse
overnight or desperately that's where
language is really important here
because I think that you can do that
within the system that we have is that
if that is red states and their
Governors and and their legislatures
were to actually put their foot down
right and trust me I live in the reddest
state in America and I get very
frustrated with exactly what it is that
you're describing here which it's like
oh you know oh will this do the 2030
plan and you know make a bunch of money
off of whatever when they when they
should be standing up to these other
states and you know filing a a lawsuit
like Texas did against Pennsylvania when
with the mail in voting and hopefully we
could have a supreme court that would
actually take up a case like that
because it was really important you're
playing became a monopoly with people
who are cheating and and they keep going
well I'll just keep trying and
eventually I'll win and the people who
are cheating death they definitively
believe they are justified in doing what
they do because they're morally right so
what we need is okay before National
divorce we need a real a realignment of
the leverage the one simple thing is
that the producers in this country of
which they're they're they're they're
growing increasingly less to just
outright say no to those cities sorry we
no longer Drive our trucks and deliver
to you
because you're destroying this country
see the problem is most people and and
the reason we're in this mess is because
most people will tell you I agree with
you but I will do nothing to bring risk
to myself Matt Strickland comes on this
show and talks about how his restaurant
was being targeted by ABC by the
government They seized all his booze
they shut him down and he refused to
back down anyone then he gets phone
calls from people saying what you did
was amazing we support you what can we
do to help and he said do the same thing
brother and then go oh no I would never
do that I will only stand back and hide
in the shadows as you assume all the
risks for yourself tell you to keep
doing it while I watch you get
steamrolled by the government and then
do nothing to support you because well
you know life's not that bad right well
and we see that kind of thing on the
internet all the time I mean just in
yeah I live where right yeah exactly and
I have two words my Twitter account
people were oh man we're terrified to
touch me because my Twitter is you are
clarified to touch me because my Twitter
No I know I think I've experienced that
and we probably all have it nobody will
come to your Aid even if they know
you're right because they just don't
want to be
you know mixed up is their drama right
yes they're cowards and that that's
really disappointing that's awesome we
did this skating event in DC and I was
warned by some industry guys they were
like hey man like you shouldn't go to DC
and do this thing people are really mad
it's going to be it's gonna be a lot of
heat and it's you know we're worried and
then I'm like dude I live here I I live
in the DC area I go skate where I feel
like skating and you know what happened
nothing the locals skated got a few fist
bumps gave out a bunch of skateboards a
crowd was there we cheered we all skated
we filmed nobody said anything negative
these people live in the state of fear
over a boogeyman that doesn't exist yes
and they're scared to speak up because
you know what maybe the reason YouTube
allows a show like this is that us
talking about wokeness in The Cult puts
it in the minds of people to be afraid
right that when we say people are afraid
because these things happen that
reinforces it I don't know man it's it's
frustrating that we get to the point
where Marjorie Taylor green says
National divorce and there are people
who are still just like no no no slow
down on their Democrats and I'm like
dude
if we were at the point where we know
for a fact that California is bringing
in non-citizens to fluff their numbers
and give themselves more Federal power
that is a very serious Act of corruption
that is destroying the union and Texas
knows it and Oklahoma knows it and
Nebraska knows it all of these red
States know it and they do nothing they
let California cheat and then just do
nothing
what are they supposed to do
well uh I think the federal government
well I'll put it this way
at this point it seems like the federal
government is unwilling to enforce these
rules the Texas V Pennsylvania lawsuit
was a good start but they need to start
cutting off trade and and it should be
like sanctions the idea that Texas
allowed a man's child to be taken to
California for sex change surgery or
medication is insane why would Texas
allow that to happen imagine if you
lived in a state and a parent said that
they were going to bring a child across
state lines to kill them for medical
assistance and death and the state went
that's fine it's like so there's no law
protecting life okay we got a problem
there Texas or any other state that
allows a person to cross across its
borders to commit crimes elsewhere then
we have no rule of law I mean imagine if
you you took a kid across state lines
the federal government agrees with what
this woman is doing to this kid and they
won't do anything about it
and no one else will okay you you could
say that we can't have a national
divorce but as far as I'm concerned when
you're at the point where Colorado says
No Limit abortions and Oklahoma says no
abortions at all and California says sex
change for kids and Texas says no but
the federal government is siding with
one side that's breaking the law there
is no government there is no United
States there is no Constitution it is
simply people holding on to an image or
a memory they once had wishing that it
was still true but it's not but then the
option is just force right the uh the
option is loss of confidence the option
is as a business don't trade with
California look at what the liberal
states do they bar their employees in
the government from going to Atlanta or
otherwise they they put restrictions on
companies doing business with other
countries I'm sorry other other states
uh other counties we'll recover it that
way but Republicans don't do the same
Mitch McConnell sits down and goes well
slow down
and people keep voting for him voting
for McCarthy and we get the same thing
over and over there's an economic reason
for that because you have like States
like Oklahoma on the whole do not have
the money in the income that California
does right I mean they don't have the
business they don't have Google I mean
they're starting to get it now Google's
starting to inject itself into red
states which I'm just like guys hey
don't don't be careful what you wish for
here you know um but they they don't
have the the large businesses you know
in Montana that they do in in California
and so they're in many ways dependent
upon that that 21st century income that
they see the world going towards and so
it it they feel like it's a little bit
they've got them over the barrel
California it's the fifth if it was a
country it would be the fifth largest
economy in the world right alone just
the state it apparently pulled in 3.63
trillion dollars in 2022 Gross Gross
State product
uh the largest in the United States the
largest economy of any state in the
United States so it's kind of like
asking a kid to stop eating the breast
milk of its mother like no it's like
California is our Western economy like
it is the the mouth of our entire Port
system essentially thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8 pm and become a member over
at timcast.com for uncensored members
only shows exclusive thanks for hanging
out and we'll see you all next time